تم إطلاق صاروخين باليستيين بين عشية وضحاها
على سفينة حربية أمريكية، وحدث هذا الآن
في خليج عدن، ويبدو أنه
الأحدث ضمن سلسلة من
الهجمات العديدة التي شنتها إيران ضد المتمردين الحوثيين
من اليمن ضدنا وضد قوات التحالف
منذ هجوم حماس الإرهابي في أكتوبر/تشرين الأول.
السابع، بدأت هذه الحادثة الأخيرة بنداء
استغاثة من
سفينة شحن تجارية في المنطقة، وقد
قدمت لنا كاتي بوليس من سي إن إن هذا التقرير، ما الذي
تعرفه أكثر عن كاتي
بو كيت، نعم، دعنا نستعرض
تسلسل الأحداث هنا يوم الأحد
ناقلة تجارية تحتوي على
حمض الفوسفوريك مع بعض الارتباطات الواضحة
لشركة مملوكة لإسرائيليين أرسلت
نداء الاستغاثة أه قائلة إنها تعرضت
لهجوم أثناء عملها في
خليج إيدن يو إس إس ماسون
صاروخ بحري موجه مدمرة صواريخ موجهة
تابعة للبحرية  استجابت الولايات المتحدة، التي
تعمل أيضًا في الخليج وقبالة
سواحل الصومال كجزء من
فرقة عمل لمكافحة القرصنة، لنداء
الاستغاثة هذا عندما وصلوا
إلى السفينة التجارية ووجدوا خمسة
خاطفين مسلحين على متن السفينة التي
قفز منها الخاطفون.  من
السفينة التجارية إلى قارب صغير خاص بهم
انطلقوا مسرعين، أعطت مدمرة الصواريخ الأمريكية أه
تشيس وتمكنت في النهاية من
الحصول على استسلام هؤلاء
الخاطفين الآن لم
تحدد الولايات المتحدة علنًا من هم هؤلاء الخاطفون المسلحون الخمسة
ولكن ما نحن  ما نعرفه هو
أنه في الساعات التي تلت هذه الحادثة،
تم إطلاق صاروخين باليستيين من
منطقة سيطرة الحوثيين في اليمن في
الاتجاه العام لمايسون،
وسقطت تلك الصواريخ دون ضرر في
خليج عدن على بعد حوالي 10 أميال بحرية
من السفينة، لذلك لا يمكننا  لم تقع
إصابات بيننا، ولكن بالنسبة للمسؤولين الأمريكيين، يعد
هذا نوعًا من الإشارة المثيرة للقلق إلى
أن المسلحين الحوثيين في اليمن
قد يسعون إلى تصعيد الصراع
الدائر حاليًا في غزة بين
إسرائيل وحماس، تمامًا كما هو الحال مع
تقارير رائعة، شكرًا لك كما هو الحال دائمًا جون،
حسنًا مع  نحن الآن اللواء المتقاعد بالجيش
جيمس سباير، مارك سي إن إن،
محلل عسكري ورئيس
الإستراتيجية الجيوسياسية في أكاديمية الأوراق المالية في العنكبوت،
دعنا نلقي نظرة على ما
حدث للتو في خليج أيدن مع هذا، كما
تعلمون أن سفينة الشحن هذه هناك
محاولة اختطاف القفزات الأمريكية  للمساعدة
ثم الصواريخ التي تم إطلاقها من
الحوثيين في اليمن، هذا عنكبوت جانبي
أم أن هذا هو نوع الشيء الذي يمكن أن
نراه أكثر في
الأيام القادمة أعتقد أننا سنرى المزيد من
هذا جون بوضوح، يبدو الأمر كما لو أن القفازات
قد خلعت  بسبب الغضب
الدولي، الغضب العالمي عندما
ينظرون إلى ما يحدث في غزة
بغض النظر عما يحاول الجيش الإسرائيلي
تحقيقه مع حماس، فقد أصبح هذا الآن
نقاشًا حول
التعامل الوحشي مع
القضية الفلسطينية الكبرى، لذا فقد قامت إيران  عادت
إلى وكلائها، وكانت الصيحات واحدة
من هؤلاء وتقول إن اللعبة العادلة افعل ما
تحتاج إلى القيام به، لقد حصلت على دعمنا، ومن
المؤكد أنك تحظى بدعمنا. إيران
لا تضغط على الزناد ولا تسمح
بكل واحدة من هذه الارتباطات ولكن
بالتأكيد الحدود  بين ما هو
مناسب وما هو غير مناسب
من وجهة نظرهم أصبح مفتوحًا على مصراعيه الآن
وهذا ما ترونه